Sin City is one step closer to landing
its first major professional sports
franchise the NHL received applications
from Las Vegas and Quebec City for a
scheduled expansion before the 2017 to
2018 season joining the league comes at
a big price though the bids have a 10
million dollar application fee and an
overall expansion fee of 500 million at
least according to the Seattle Times
Bloomberg Sports as Evan Novi Williams
joins us now so the NHL looking to
expand what's different about this
expansion versus the last expansion well
in the 90s the NHL expanded in the
southern region they put teams in in
Phoenix in Atlanta that didn't work out
so you didn't it did not work out so
well I mean obviously when you think of
you think of hockey fans you think of
them up north in Canada in the northern
United States and Gary Bettman wanted to
make this an entire country league and
he did that and some of those teams did
not do very well they took a team from
Winnipeg they took a team from Quebec
the team they put in Atlanta left
obviously moved back to Canada if you
look at the lowest teams in terms of
attendance Carolina's right there
Florida is right there Phoenix went
bankrupt a couple years ago so so the
90s expansion the NHL went through was
not a huge success but they seemed to be
doing things a little better now is it
possible that people who grow up surfing
and playing in the sand
don't play ice hockey very much I mean
people don't care in general about ice
hockey so if you will watch the Stanley
Cup like 107 it's it's really little
compared to any other American yeah so
the Stanley Cup doesn't get the ratings
that the World Series can then regular
season games get negative ratings
yeah the regular season doesn't do that
well either but the NHL especially in
the playoffs is growing its base there
are sports fans now that are watching
the NHL playoffs especially as Carla can
attest to it's actually edible for
something like the a major league
baseball which has seen drop-off in
interest from the younger generally and
the NHL is doing it in the smarter way
this year obviously Quebec is is one of
those areas that is hockey crazy up
there in Canada and Las Vegas is just an
interesting experiment well yeah
Quebec City makes sense Las Vegas though
and we were just talking about this
doesn't make sense it's in the middle of
the desert
a drought how have no other pro sports
teams right yeah so team leagues oh hi
oh is an interesting experiment you know
it didn't work out so well leaks have
been very hesitant to put teams in Las
Vegas it's partially a function of the
betting atmosphere there and partially a
function of concern that there isn't an
ever year-round fan base that you would
just get people in that are visiting Las
Vegas he wouldn't have season ticket
holders and things like that
NHL is really the first to kind of make
that first step and see you know what
let's give it a shot and Bill Foley the
billionaire who's gonna be the owner of
the team if their applications approved
he says he has 13,000 season ticket
applications commitments already Wow so
if that's true and the team moves there
it could be a major success all right
this is all about Gary Bettman legacy as
well what's the cement it'll be
interesting no doubt all right I mean
nobody Williams thank you so much our
resident Bloomberg News sports reporter